Adam and James baby bok city ok yo games
I'm a little James right video games yes
hello and welcome to Adam and James play
video games I am indeed Adam and hear in
the background is like always our gyms
hide info right Jimbo today our task is
to take selfies the difference with
these selfies is that we have to take
them at the moment somebody dies ok so
for example do you fancy trying to kill
yourself oh you know what I was just
gonna do it I was gonna try and surprise
you suicide selfies fine wood design are
the vinyl sign is a great idea if you
could hit the V or just in front of the
V in front of the V oh my see that you
know I'm lying that's that's a pixel
I've got to em up Oh zexal ok here we go
um is a long drop let's just say there's
a long drop ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba
ba ba ba ba ba ba i'm still miles our
Murph am I gonna hit that freaking sign
oh I just heard your helicopter blow up
right I can see the sign now I can even
spell II towel and I've got a wanted
level oh crap about a helicopter musta
hit someone I'm speeding up forgot I'm
gonna miss it I'm gonna miss this get
ready now a common in this second I'm on
the me can't even see you in it oh yeah
oh love flying in fact I've got a new
game come over here get on a letter is
this game dive off the vine would sign
on to pedestrians
oh you know me too well right I think we
can jump off this and parachute and land
safely we're about if I jump off this
well here we go oh my oh my god I could
fall right I love you brother let's do
this as I'm dear man I love you t tell
of you three I just fell on up come on
up right irony let me stand them a
parachute yeah I'm gonna take yourself
from the bottom and I'm just gonna leap
and die okay you do you do look like
you're in a suicide bid here oh I'm
bali's appalling oh let's look so ace
what we just wave bye-bye James do you
pause then go for it dude just walk
straight off all right let's see what we
got it's really hard to distinguish
where you are cuz you're the same color
as the girder behind you let's send us
radio this is a long buddy matter am I
in shot dad I'm right on the edge back
to one of my favorites this is it a back
real world oh my god how am I still on
this I'm floating in mid-air oh oh oh I
think I got that I think I got it got ya
I absolutely move that oh poor lad
skills welcome to ban would oh this is
terrifying I'm on the top I kit I can't
see diddly squat they tell me wonder how
you ready i I couldn't be I think this
is the end for me Adam bad enough I
wanted of a little Jew before big I hi I
don't go it oh I took a boat overview
shadow or just got two grand for good
behavior that's wrong on so many levels
this is james climb into his death he's
had enough of it all right I bet start
my rubbish my god it looks like you're
doing a magic trick and you just making
me levitate above your hand okay come
get it get it get him okay I'm this guy
here baby nezumi right selfie I'm gonna
set myself on fire take a selfie I'm
johnny Knoxville welcome to jackass
thank you what if one of us stands on
the roller coaster track and takes a
selfie as they're about to hit be hit by
the coaster come on man let's go jumping
good a Buddha good good oh this is scary
this is scary this week on dude we're
comin to get ya don't don't don't
understand I'm dead whoo hey yo you have
a nice time yo stop biting at people on
let's roll across the lake your
destructans hey I'll run somebody open
you've got to try and get the exact
second I hid them in a selfie three two
one now good you look like she's giving
him a hurricanrana I was a man on the
chair we need to hit him with a car
let's do this guy has no idea what's
about to happen bomb squad he's looking
to this guy like why me
he knows why yeah yeah we called it
where the hell are you going I'm 10
ultimate selfish this is okay this is
good bit lower bit lower they're like
have no idea oh I don't think it counted
I'm falling off the building there early
they can knock you with my wing well
what you are my wingman I'm gonna try
and get loads of vehicles on a crossroad
so you can crash into the food that does
sound like ultimate selfie suicide I'm
going am I hate me for the buses all
right oh my god it is so cozy circle
there's tons of vehicles here down down
oh right I'm go game for us before we
can kill ourselves in the Hollywood side
we've got to try and fly through is the
O's in Hollywood vinewood sorry how far
up do you reckon we should go to try
this I think the further up the mall
control will have a Rick god I'm the
opposite i think the further more can go
wrong all right now case you go ahead by
after you dude I'm so close oh I'm not
near enough i'm not near enough I'm not
dying for that I'm fine I could not I
could not have been closer right Jim's
it's been an absolute pleasure I've
loved doing these suicidals selfies so
to speak but I think it's time to go
back to what we always know there's only
one way to end this video and it's to
say good night sweet prince I'm going to
leap to my death it's up to you what you
do my friend good night everyone will
see you next time this was a demand Jim
play video games
what was that noise oh don't know